Curfew is now in effect.
All unauthorized citizens must stay indoors.
Tensions rise as we enter the 213th week of lockdown.
A grim new reality emerges.
COVID-23 has mutated.
Beginning thermal scan.
Thermal scan normal.
A horrifying new development today...
New data confirms the virus attacks the brain tissue.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa! I'm immune.
I'm immune.
Worldwide death toll rises to over 110 million.
All infected Americans are being forced into quarantine camps.
Beginning thermal scan: three, two one.
Anomaly detected.
Armed guards will be arriving in four to six hours.
You must not attempt to leave your home or you will be shot on sight.
I'm trying to save the one person left in my life that matters to me.
I can't help you.
What you're talking about is illegal.
Nico.
I'm here.
And remember, stay safe, sane and sanitized.